a ver qué efectos ha tenido el fin del
título 42 en la región de América Latina
qué tal Muchas gracias por la invitación
Santiago mira creo que más allá del fin
de título 42 y las nuevas medidas que
fueron anunciadas también por el
gobierno de Estados Unidos que
acompañaron también la finalización de
esta medida Lo importante es entender
este fenómeno como desde un punto de
vista hemisférico y desde una
perspectiva panorámica no en el sentido
de que para comprender lo que está
sucediendo en la región tenemos que
entender toda la hoja de ruta que toman
las personas que en movimientos mixtos
de personas refugiadas inmigrantes están
tomando no solamente mirando digamos los
países de destinos las miradas están muy
focalizadas no en la frontera de México
con Estados Unidos sino también de los
países de los cuales salen y los países
a través que transitan para poder llegar
en ese sentido lo que sí te puedo decir
es que ha habido desde no solamente años
este año digamos con la finalización
sino un fenómeno que venimos observando
Es que la gran mayoría de las personas
que se están desplazando forzosamente en
la región permanecen en América Latina y
en ese sentido es importante observar
por ejemplo que aquellas personas que no
han podido encontrar una solución
sostenible En aquellos países que han
llegado están tomando quizás este
decisiones para continuar su camino
hacia el norte como estamos viendo en
las imágenes que están proyectando donde
podemos observar esto es justamente la
selva del Darién en La Peligrosa selva
de dariel que limita con Panamá y
Colombia donde ya desde el 2021 venimos
observando Un aumento progresivo de
personas que cruzan estas frontera para
darte un ejemplo nomás una cifra
concreta 250.000 personas cruzaron la
selva del Darién en el 2022 y según
estadísticas queda el gobierno de Panamá
y también este año según estimaciones de
gobierno de Panamá
ha alcanzado a 150.000 no más de 150.000
las personas que están cruzando la selva
del taller Entonces es importante en
principio analizar la situación a largo
plazo y poder ofrecer soluciones
sostenibles a estas personas mirando
también las causas que provocan el
desplazamiento forzado pero también la
asistencia humanitaria y las situaciones
las soluciones que tenemos que brindar
mientras las personas están transitando
diversos de la región bueno precisamente
hablando de soluciones no como usted
decía desde acnur como plantean que se
podría gestionar esta problemática
migratoria que como usted decía afecta a
países muy particulares de la región de
América Latina
las soluciones no pueden por supuesto
venir solamente de un solo país no
pueden venir tampoco solamente de
organismos internacionales como el acnur
la agencia de la ONU para los refugiados
sino que tiene que ser una una solución
donde todas las partes tenemos que
colaborar y además tenemos que
implementar una visión estratégica e
integral de de la situación desde
desplazamiento forzado para nosotros
desde la cruz justamente la respuesta
que estamos brindando es en coordinación
con los gobiernos de cada uno de los
países pero también focalizando Y esta
es nuestra prioridad es la de atender a
las necesidades humanitarias y de
protección garantizando el acceso al
sistema de asilo de las personas que así
lo requieren y también déjame decir
solamente esto último es muy importante
la desinformación que existe respecto a
las distintas medidas que existen en la
región y las condiciones como te
mencionaba por ejemplo la peligrosidad
de atravesar la selva del Ariel por eso
desde arnur estamos desarrollando
campañas de información para convertir
justamente redes este delictivas que
juegan con esta situación y con las
personas y la esperanza de las personas
por ejemplo podrás ver desde Colombia
con la campaña de somos panas Colombia
en Panamá recientemente se ha lanzado la
campaña Confía en el tucán y en México
la campaña en Jaguar para poder brindar
información que en última instancia para
nosotros también es brindar protección